yes did you did you
hey did you raid ron white's closet
excuse me couple things number one these
do they come with a tommy bahama shirt
dude
these are my on clouds and they're wide
they're wide so
daddy's feet need to spread out this is
your toes because you've got got to
myself some problems okay i'm wrong with
that yeah i can't pull it can't be
pulling my toe in if i pull my toe in it
stops the blood from getting my heel
they're finding a lot of plantar
fasciitis might be there yeah yeah your
toes roll
on the branch called never getting [ __ ]
again dude i'm walking on clouds and
these are [ __ ] dope as they say
no those are cool dude yeah they are
cool yeah you know they're not but i
like how you ride for your boy you know
but i like the reason chappelle like
rocks those because he knows that nobody
else is ever gonna have them and we give
you [ __ ] for them so you double down on
them it's very punk of you it is very
very fun you wear the same exact black
pants and they're high waters and i
really like that about you actually you
i feel like you have multiple peers
right yeah
because you're not lighting the ass
you're not no the upper thighs at all
and it [ __ ] and it sucks yeah i don't
know well you're you've got you're built
for power but these also are very
comfortable shoes
sure so sure so pretty no arch support
or do they i don't know um i think i'm
flat-footed see daddy has these and that
my feet are free inside there are you
flat-footed i need white shoes too
sure i have some ideas yeah damn
narrative every shoe is white yeah those
are comfortable you gotta get those wide
jordan ones are some of the most
comfortable shoes i've ever yeah these
aren't jordan ones but i like how your
head's at all right they're the new
supreme dunk club i get from my birthday
but they are jordan act like he was far
off aren't they jordans though no not
even close no they're high-top dunks oh
sorry yeah the supreme club you were in
the area don't let them hate it well i
mean well they're yeah i guess they
they look like jordans i can see that
that's right i see that to the comments
the style the style now daddy took a
piss there's a little pee pee on them
well you just got these no you have just
gotten yeah daddy hugs the urinal you
get super up close and personal on that
urinal daddy keeps me i keep i keep it
back and i aim my pee so it hits the
slope so it's just it's sloping you piss
straight out you go i'm gonna piss
straight at that thing he doesn't
usually no you're on your phone i don't
know where these hands been you like to
catch up on emails yep you just let it
put you pull everything you know what i
like when you go into uh restaurant
bathrooms and says
fellas it's closer than you think ladies
please remain seated for the entire
performance i've never seen that it
makes me smile i've never seen that
really going somewhere first
i see them at all these restaurants
it's in zoo culture it's in tons of
restaurants oh i don't know fellas your
aim isn't good you think please get
closer please stand closer ladies please
remain seated for your entire
performance i see that you go it's give
me a good night oh yeah that's fair
tonight i drop a huge [ __ ] oh man
i'm sorry i didn't have an end for that
story yeah you [ __ ] in restaurants you
can do it no [ __ ] he'll [ __ ] anywhere
and sit on the toilet i know he'll shoot
not worried about it oh yeah i'll get on
my phone and just like i gotta give him
[ __ ] i'm like but it's dirty oh bro i'm
white but but i like to take the roll
off you know i don't like to go
undo the thing take it out the other day
i was taking [ __ ] in the restaurant
and the thing just rolled under the
other strong everybody throw that back
and you see this hand go
no thanks daddy and then you grabbed his
hand thanks daddy that's so good i go
gotcha
poopoo twins
you and then because you're really
strong you slowly
you drag it underneath
and yeah and his face is like this and
then you just pull them in it's a [ __ ]
slip and slide buddy
how did you go oh yeah oh you were
worried about kovid what do you think of
[ __ ] how about some poo poo
yeah that's my dick oops that's my dong
oh it's called a blocker you know what a
block it's called a blonde it's a
blonker tell all you're taking a blunt
you get a [ __ ] oh no no no
no yeah
um it's a form of eyewear all right well
i had a swedish guy tell me a blonker is
the other thing or is it blumpkin
oh there it is the act of defecating
into a person's hand and everything yeah
all right so wait first the verse is
getting oh oh well brian you ruined my
birthday
that
that makes you feel about it you can
give yourself dude hold on look at the
quote they give bro that girl is a
keeper not only did she let me grab her
tits last night she gave me a blanco
who the [ __ ] would want
anything like that you're getting a
[ __ ]
oh dude
in there then it quotes dude i got a
blonker yesterday this is disgusting
i'm too old to be even having this
comment yeah that's what i'm saying how
do you know this i hope you're happy
you've ruined my birthday i had a my day
was ruined this morning my morning from
what
so i have you know i have
to have coy beautiful koi and i'm still
talking about your stupid fish my turtle
got pulled out and i i didn't have head
a head or it's hands that's a bit right
i killed them yeah and then then then
my one of my kois goes missing now my
other koi won't come up to the surface i
read that if you give koi prozac they
are no longer if they're depressed
and they go down that means that they're
depressed if you give them [ __ ]
prozac they'll come to it yeah
what's stupid
number one
why are you giving
they do these experiments to see how it
works on the nervous systems of
different animals right so with fish if
they're depressed and they're they they
they go down into their hole
they come up when you give them prozac
okay okay it's kind of [ __ ] crazy so
so you did that so i it says but in
general since well-being isn't likely
paying off researchers say yeah well
here's the thing my [ __ ] fiction grow
down can i have antidepressants because
this is insane my fish got [ __ ] upset
look at this
yeah
uh but they got it from the the people
dumping their you know
yeah but they've done experiments where
the fish comes to the surface now my
fish wouldn't come to the surface i go
and buy them two [ __ ] friends two
cute coy and they're little and i swear
to god he came out they show up and now
the fish are following him and they're
sweating they won't leave each other's
side was he by himself yes and he was
like and now he came up i was just
leaving my yes with my two fish that's
great they're hanging out hey getting
older huh yeah but guess what hey hey
come on daddy hold on to my koi fish in
your pond yeah but guess what one won't
come out yeah i'm a little older yeah a
little bit older no i'm a yogi i'm a
yogi and i believe all things are one
now yeah sure now now you didn't give
him prozac and your fish suffers from i
didn't give him manic depressive i
didn't give him pros like i gave him two
fish as friends guess what you guessed
what happened this morning morale went
up he ate him that [ __ ] took my
two baby fish yeah and they're gone so i
teased them and that [ __ ] cat or that
[ __ ] raccoon
killed both my [ __ ] fish wait
you don't think the big fish are just
yeah
yeah no the fish no the big fish the big
fish literally now won't come they do
that yeah they kill you they kill each
other though i don't think it's the cat
you keep blaming the cats no because
these these fish are too too big for him
to eat wait at first i thought it was
raccoon size difference isn't that much
big i don't know if it's raccoon or cat
i'm getting a [ __ ] nightcam and i'm
going to find out oh you know what i
would do what not have a koi pond no i
won't oh you know what i would do what
nothing i want you know i would do what
just walk by everything go oh well no
okay no i feel bad for my [ __ ] koi oh
you all should do is talk what if tiger
loved that koi fish
we go to the mall and there's koi fish
you know and then he gets over it yeah
they're stupid you know but um get a
piranha get a bunch of piranhas in there
i'm not getting a bunch of piranhas in
there that's not cool wouldn't that be
kind of cool though you mean if that's
the same they call you brian the piranha
guy
yeah would that be cool i don't think
that's legal oh yeah you can do that you
can have piranha
it's it's a myth that they have feeding
friends if you put your hand in they
don't have feet in front rogan used to
have piranhas and then he had um he had
piranhas and then next door like in the
same tank with a barrier he had goldfish
and he had a label on it on the goldfish
and it said death row
and he would take a goldfish and throw
him in the [ __ ] yeah and the piranhas
because that's what that's that's what
they eat yeah
oh god definitely yeah they're weird
though but movies make it seem like
piranhas like if you jumped into
piranhas
yeah you'd be fine oh yeah it doesn't
work which i never knew no yeah yeah
yeah it's weird huh yeah they won't [ __ ]
well what a weird thing a lot of us
about they'll [ __ ] with you if um
if you're injured and there's blood
if you're dead but yeah not a bigger
thing but they don't do like that
feeding friends where they're biting it
down to the boat yeah oh like you know
they could skeletonize you in a couple
yeah it made it seem like they're like
pretty high it was terrifying oh they're
cool yeah they sell that petsmart
petsmart doesn't really sell animals
anymore i don't think well a lot of
those animals would be people get bored
of them flush them down the toilet
this is the problem with crocodiles back
in the 70s you could get crocodiles you
can get actual nile crocodiles
and the problem was people look this up
chin because people they found nile
crocodiles in the florida everglades
it'd be tough flushing i like
now i like your idea but let's just
let's look at it logically right think
of a toilet like then what do you think
no they don't do that they would drop
them in the streams they dropped them in
the in the oh no those little not
flushing
toilets i know they would drop them in
the you know like canelo
oh yeah the crocodile thrives in that
look at this [ __ ] like it's crazy well
it's like uh pablo escobar had those
hippos in colombia well now they have a
huge problem this is [ __ ] terrifying
by a huge hippo problem i mean there's
like six of them there seems to be
another major invasive reptile wasteland
the nile crocodile yes the everglades
are full of crocodiles but they're
native to america these nile crocodiles
come from africa but how these crocs
make their way across the atlantic ocean
and how they end up swimming around the
everglades that is the big question
the university of florida heritage said
he isn't sure how they got
into the wild over here because they
certainly didn't swim from africa knock
rocks have been captured in the
everglades in 2009 2011 2014 ever
reports from locals that strange-looking
alligators the scientists and his
colleagues captured and tested the croc
after some dna testing was done it was
determined these crocodiles are nile
crocodiles and the three were probably
related to each other however they are
not
matched to any nile crocs in any florida
licensed florida attractions well we go
hard on the animals that four-year-old
got eaten a lot of got you know taken
away at disney world that is so
but dude you cannot [ __ ] around with
nile crocodiles no no no no they will
and then also they have like ana they
find anacondas and [ __ ] in florida and
they're not natural no and also burmese
burmese pipelines they're right which is
not natural to florida you know they eat
everything yeah so now you get money for
killing burmese pythons really yes
everybody does it's kind of cool though
you know it's like why not have them
around yeah and you also want to kill
you want to go ahead and kill yourself
some some crocodiles some nile
crocodiles don't [ __ ] around too
aggressive but i thought they didn't
[ __ ] with you unless you oh
crocodiles
oh my god oh they search for you oh yeah
dude oh yeah don't be on a paddle board
because i get to them dog
they're aggressive they will eat thick
really a thick vegan mcnugget yeah
they're just all about it oh they're too
terrible oh i thought they didn't [ __ ]
with people oh no you would have real
problems if you ran into one look at
that thing the other one pulling up poor
elephants [ __ ] noses
yeah they're very aggressive yeah
they'll eat anything no guys 200 wait
what a weird spread
attacks a year 275 to 745
63 are fatal not good odds fellas yeah
the minute they suppose estimated 30
attacks a year by saltwater crocs which
are 50 because they have the strongest
bite right either way it does 63 to 50
percent you get a whole your odds are
not good
dude yeah
you've seen the wonk
that's an elephant look at how big that
croc is are you joking me
that's terrifying that thing [ __ ]
lifted it right out isn't it crazy i
mean
clearly a crocodile is a goddamn
dinosaur yeah but they still say that
birds are closer to dive swords than
crocodiles i beg to differ that was that
british twins
yeah that thing that thing took that
guy's hand off oh british twins attacked
by crocodile oh they they made it though
they beat the odds
first of all why are they swimming where
were they
in mexico she was in a coma yeah but
that's mexico so that tends to be a
different kind of croc yeah it's just
like a floating lagoon
yeah don't do that
croc polder underwater yeah not for me
man
terrifying brian remember we were making
fun of your story about the kid that was
in the tree
lightning
whatever yes someone messaged me and
they were like no he's not lying about
that no that's a true story of course
like it is a true story
i'm sorry i made fun of you in front of
you for that i have an irrational fear
of crocodiles yeah so crocs oh yeah
terrifying
and sociopathic giant sociopathic
social media
but when you say this
you saw the amazing video of that
cheetah and cheetahs are a little faster
than him oh it caught him behind his
neck it just well the cheese is drinking
at the water hole and you see how fast
that [ __ ] thing no it just comes out
of the water and puts his whole body in
his mouth
bring that up you ever seen a leprechaun
she's never seen it you ever seen this
camera so it sucks for all of us because
i've seen it so many times
and the fans definitely i do like those
videos
well there's there's that one where oh
no i think it's a tight bengal tiger
gets the crop behind the neck and just
crunchy
crunch well that's like that's like oh
yeah this is so stupid watch how fast
this is i'll show a picture that's like
that's like [ __ ]
there you go
you know there you go you're not doing
[ __ ] about that oh god i didn't even see
him coming no it's so fast it's
you don't that's what's crazy of how
fast like someone put too sad such a
shame [ __ ] that's what it's supposed to
happen mother nature
cold-hearted [ __ ]
she's a courtesy of spouse yeah i want
to see yeah i love dude i can watch
these videos i follow nature's metal
then you've seen
so he knows something's in the water he
does he's just thirsty
and he's trying to he's just thirsty
drink that mud water
oh i didn't see him i know you can't i
did not see him
holy sh oh that's not good
dude now let's go for a little swim
cheetah
oh can you not breathe underwater that's
how quickly it happens oh you don't have
a snorkel look at that that's a that's a
tiny little pond oh his friend's like
jesus christ yeah i do where did randy
go
what happened to randy randy randy is
food they don't even know what the [ __ ]
to make of this [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] this mud
so now every time what's the big deal
you could die tiger tiger swim tigers
[ __ ] yeah every time you're
thirsty you could die
yeah that's mother nature you know like
that crocodile that's just a wild
cross and those those teasers are pieces
of [ __ ] too like all of my mother nature
well you never you never think that as a
cheater you have to worry about
crocodiles but even lions have to [ __ ]
oh yeah everybody guys watch their peas
and kids crocodiles
them wild boars too oh all of them
they get got
it's not good i wonder how many times
i've talked about crocodiles you think a
thousand seven thousand yeah sometimes i
was gonna say we brought that video up
all the years we've done parking
ten times yeah and it's always the same
thing boy they can kill you we just go
over the same thing
even before that game he was doing this
oh yeah i've never stopped
sharks used to be my thing and then
great whites saw people swimming with
them but salty's and and niles they
don't that it's primordial i'm like i'm
terrified oh someone sent me a video
dealing with a hammerhead [ __ ]
you put the hands on the like
they were holding them they were holding
the back of it
i laughed at it
yeah we've been over that
i'm not [ __ ] with bull sharks great
whites tigers old tigers don't [ __ ] with
anything outside that i don't care
everything else i don't like jellyfish
that's that's a that's another thing
they're creepy
like the one we saw yep where where were
we at uh
florida florida that's right my buddy's
job i was like where the [ __ ] were we
yes my buddy joey he lives in he has a
house in new zealand and he goes this is
why i got to come out he sent me a video
this morning of him on a on jet skis he
and his friend and orcas are just like
playing with the bubbles from the jet
skis they're right there like you can
touch them slightly
like
or you can just do it up here
yeah dude it's all the way across the
other side of the world that's right
it's a little bit farther you get any
jet skis you know i think it's a day
ahead of you yeah it's such a i've been
there it's or you've been yeah so far
yeah
nice
you know
nice nice you've been in hawaii
and jessica in hawaii five hours away
yeah same thing yeah same thing yeah
yeah i'm not a it's hard for me to go
far
you know like uh this beautiful view
i've never sent my buddy like you're
missing out dude i'm [ __ ] yeah that's
a weird i'm in australia get your ass
here yeah you know because you know
you're not coming
you know
no i'll bring my kids let me plan it six
months from now dude yeah that's what
i'm doing i mean bring my kids are you
yeah you could just want them to see
what you're talking about
you can fish collect clams on the beach
right here
i can't i can go to
yeah be nice
yeah save the trip
save the 40 grand spent on play thing is
when you live in correct me if i'm wrong
but if you live in l.a especially if you
live in where i live like and i got a
view of the ocean
it
doesn't get a lot better in some parts
of la if you have a view of the ocean
yeah i know saint bart's i know the
caribbean yeah but the oh it's just
beautiful in florida i like the ocean
out there yeah it's chill the ocean's
chill yeah
we wrote the we wrote jessica's jet skis
in my
maybe i'll do that i'm going to be in
miami on the 25th 22nd
what should i do it's everywhere
somebody goes like this guy who has a
house in miami i mean i go i'll be in
miami i'm doing stand up there he goes
where in miami i go the miami improv he
goes where's that i go
doral and he goes
not miami
right outside miami it's not like you're
on south beach close though he's like no
it's not no no it's not uh it's pretty
close but it's not yeah because we
stayed downtown and we yeah i'm staying
on north page oh i hear that's better i
don't know
those jet skis are fun though they're
cool i was terrified i thought that
[ __ ]
even jet skis like i've been on them and
i was i only need 20 minutes yeah yeah
that's my sunglasses unless you're a kid
if you're a kid you're like kids
you know after 20 you think 20 is a hot
second on that ski
jet ski can get
the only place i did jet skis where i i
could see living and disappearing uh
because i was scuba diving was tahiti
was in bora bora
it's the most beautiful place i've ever
been in my life you have you stay in a
hut where you can see
it's it's glass yeah a lot of flowers
glass floors i know and you can see
nothing but tropical fish move there
hey move there and jet ski everyday
brian
i would swim and spearfish too dude and
i can't i'd eat off the land
four days of that
two four days dude after two days i'm
like
oh we're back on the we're gonna go on
the jet ski yeah
do you know what happened to me there
it's exciting why don't you get stung by
two days no two days i'm i'm scoop i'm
snorkeling it's great scuba dive it's
all good
and then
then you wake up and there's a beach and
it's really nice and after a while you
should get used to it does anybody want
to play volleyball is there can we do
anything right yeah yeah cause you just
wanna i don't care where i'm at in the
world three days and i'm out man three
days that's the love that's a lovely
thing about stand up
three days three days
well it's great that's true depending on
the city after two years oh i got
another one
but that's yeah it's true
been honest
yeah yeah man that's the thing about
retirement or whatever it might be like
you know who where's that blue zone
okinawa where they live till you know a
hundred and [ __ ] ten and they they
don't have a word for retirement they
actually don't retire the community is
great and where you are 85 and you're
still working
uh one of the blue zones yeah okinawa
japan
they live till they're a thousand is she
the oldest lady in the world oh yeah
dude it's it's it's very i think they
have more less cancer less heart disease
and dementia than americans and women
they're living really any women i think
they're all really tiny
yes they're all really small which helps
you yes it does ikagi
um
they rely on a plant based diet
so you know what this stuff you know
yeah that's what it says yeah but they
also that's not true because tim ferriss
went and studied them they eat a lot of
pork and they eat a lot of meals of
stir-fried vegetables sweet potatoes and
tofu are high nutrients low in calories
you know you know what they are you know
what they're boring i'd rather die at 70
red meat well they have a strong family
squirrel of june yeah but they're all
twenty people you know they are small
like there's no big grams oh so they eat
cauliflower the biggest thing they eat
is sweet potatoes they eat a [ __ ] ton of
sweets six seven percent sweet potatoes
yeah it sounds like oh they might live
forever but their life is miserable
like they live on yeah he just balls
deep in sweet potatoes all the time rice
fish meat two percent
legumes
my my charts the complete opposite of
that hey that's their culture let them
have hey dude yeah
no again they're living to their
gardening
soy no thanks maintaining my uh
traditional dude they're living another
150 but they're paying them
social networks these safety nets then
financial and emotional support but also
i bet you they're entered like their
excitement level is just always at a two
like no one ever comes in like there's
no big energy there's no breaking news
you know yeah plant a medical gardener
have an attitude
have an attitude yep
have an attitude a hardship tempered
attitudes endowed okinawans with it they
let difficult earliers remain in the
past while they enjoyed today's simple
pleasures they've learned to be likable
and keep younger people in their company
well into their old age hey i could live
there
you think you could i could do it brian
who though i'd be the [ __ ]
are
you talking to
[Laughter]
you just said you were in bora bora and
you were bored after two days
you're gonna go
chill rice with these people and okay
sweet potatoes well the best story is
the giant squash they found that day
possible i would have to kill myself and
everybody's this big and you're obsessed
with that drive me to do parties it's
such a simple life of course something
crazy it's such a simple life yeah i
wish i could be like that i haven't i i
have fantasies and i'm very serious
about fool we're living a [ __ ] small
house in the country and raising animals
and growing my own food you gonna raise
animals now hey hold on you gonna raise
that i know you too well hey when you
say fantasy do you mean a nightmare for
you
who
are you talking to dude
that would be a night look i would feed
my chickens and they're like no you
wouldn't you don't matter yeah go buddy
you want a reality check you know what
happened what after a week all those
animals would starve because you would
forget to feed them you'd be off talking
to the neighbors like what's wrong with
the goat like oh [ __ ] i forgot to feed
them
you know i have to wake up early i can't
imagine you think you can't wake up at
10 when you want no the because the
cockadoo's up it's 4 30 a.m yeah that
[ __ ] chicken he's like
like i gotta go feed the chicks
and then when it snows
no i don't know no no no no kids you're
going to find a party i want to be a
gentleman farmer and i want to have a
restaurant attached to my farm i want to
do it
was it farm to table yes but i want to
have a restaurant that's run so me
running a restaurant and a farm because
that'd be a lot of fun that's not a lot
of work because you dialed in on that
stuff because you're you're on top of
this stuff you're organized
super there's a better chance of me
starting center for the lakers you know
what i'm saying like this this ain't
happening for me they haven't for you no
but i want to be that guy sometimes you
think i get tired of going through
phases yeah you go through phases but
you're you're tired of that
unfortunately you have to have friends
to say hey
no you're not i get it like you want to
live in the blue zone with the best joke
we've heard all day right
right am i right my phone my father's a
little bit like susceptible to this i
told you like he called me up because
we're going bear hunting in alaska i go
you don't like guns and you love bears
you're not going to shoot a barrage
because i'll call you back
we're going deep sea fishing yeah then
the best is he met this guy who was like
i guess a billionaire but he collected
train sets okay
the most expensive train system he had
just spit on ideas because i've seen a
lot of first 48.
pedophile you think well right
billionaire individual i don't know
i don't know it's very strange my spidey
senses
but he had like he had rooms where he
had these intricate like locomotive
trains and it was that was just run
through his room but it was his life
it's a board billionaire he's been doing
it he's two he's two weeks yeah he'd
been known as he was a kid he was
obsessed with it my father was so
impressed he comes home my dad is like
like me and you he's [ __ ] he gets
into it he's not doing any of that and
he goes
i
he he ordered some train
toy train magazines because he wanted to
maybe get into in his home oh no that's
a weird hobby
you got to be [ __ ] kidding me you're
going to have a room full of transit no
you're not you're not they're not just
displayed they actually move oh they're
they're oh yeah
there's a whole city you can spend a
hundred times you could build new york
and build the train around
i find collectors i find people who
collect [ __ ] very very weird like mike
mike's the headphones that thick boy
yeah he collects cards yeah it's
cars cards see now i wish
cars i wish i said cars cars a little
bit right there trading cards cards is
that yeah that's it like collectors are
uh this is what he's doing brian yeah
but you can build like full cities my
brother's into it when we were kids but
so it's like legos then he turned nine
and was like i'm not into trains anymore
that's right you lose your it's a lot of
work some people do not lose their
interest
yeah i wonder what that is or they get
so rich and they're like i can build the
trains that i've always wanted to build
it's actually kind of [ __ ] dope no it
is if you have the patience
i remember my mom dated this guy who's
super into trains and he had the whole
city and we'd touch and he'd freak the
[ __ ] out
my mom got a fight with him she's like
it's a toy of course they're gonna touch
it yeah i think they broke up but not
when you paint the houses yourself and
you have little sticks no that's
actually really [ __ ] dope it takes
all the time yeah this is cool chappelle
you are
you are one notch away from being a guy
like that in a good way oh what you mean
right now you don't do it
this is my [ __ ] yeah you're gonna move
to the blue zone a minute no the thing
i'll probably spend the most money on
when i start like getting like uh
probably guitars um you'll collect how
depends on what you're getting well what
do you want
uh i i mean i love fenders fender's like
my world i play a lot of television uh
do you have a fender yeah i have uh
three that's a fender okay we have three
and you want how many more um my
collection of guitars is probably
roughly around
all together like probably worth like
four grand
okay
what that's crazy what
what's wrong with brian man american
dude
[Applause]
brandon went like this
that's cool and then i went see
and now
now i had to laugh for him because he's
trying not to laugh why because your
expectation was high i would expect more
you know i don't know i don't know
guitars
how many guitars do you have leave me
alone
i have four guitars oh that one so i
have that red one right right
though right about a grand yeah but
they're they're a grand okay yeah
roughly but yeah probably the one you
want is how like your ideal guitar is
that your ideal one no the telecaster
timeline crimson transparent indian
laurel fingerboard i have that guitar
okay so we don't need that one which one
do you want no the uh the one that no
gallagher plays i think it's a gibson
three
they're not that expensive i mean i was
thinking more yeah it was a typing
gibson now our acoustic guitars
that's the one that gibson 1964. the
three the 335 the one on
that red ted nugent plays that guitar
yeah that's cool i like those that's
that's
that's like your that's your that's the
dream now that's the north star yeah
that's like so what y'all gonna do for
me
we'll get you
we'll we'll see what the the fighting
kids right now
there he is
is that guy from ireland yeah it's that
one yeah
i'll make you a deal i'll make it
[ __ ] i'll make you a deal when you
shoot your first special i'll buy you
that guitar you better not [ __ ] me
swear to god shake on it that's great oh
yeah that's a good that's a [ __ ] that's
great all right what are you going to
give me brian you see the man of giving
no samples we're doing it together
i'll pay for it but brian put his name
on it i'm gonna
no we're going to have it engraved and
what's going to say brian ryan's the guy
that signs the card yeah it's going to
say this it's going to be like this it's
going to say
4 grand
with a question yeah wait so what you
guys thought it'd be more i don't know
guitars i think you'd be like dude my
collection worth 20 grand damn that's it
because you know why when you were like
my collection two four guitars chappelle
you went like this you went i mean my
collection is probably worth
and i was like i was like this one's
gonna be 40 grand yeah i was like
and i almost said be careful people find
out where you live live they're going to
rob you if you get done oh yeah because
i almost said that before you gave up
because if you do this if you do this i
don't know guitar is it so when you do
this i want to just show you when you go
when you go i mean it's worth now if i
do this watch if it's worth and you know
what i'm doing when i do this i'm
talking about the ferrari i bought why
yeah i bought it last year and right now
it's worth
a hundred grand more and i'm thinking a
big boy now hugo i mean i got i i have
my guitar collection it's probably worth
four grand
it's called anti-climactic dude that's
why it went brandon went oh and brennan
goes like this he goes brendan goes i
want to roast him so bad but i'm not
gonna make fun of him because he doesn't
have as much money that's not cool then
he's turning
so anyway and i was like i'm not letting
that side wait time to make some [ __ ]
money
you're gonna make money and you're gonna
make a lot of money and you're awesome
but uh but i just love that you do that
and it's probably already making money
headlining dude yeah yeah you shoot your
first special i'll buy that guitar i'm
down for that 100 i'll shoot that [ __ ]
tomorrow now here's another question
here's my other question what you put
out of a 15 minutes budget yeah he's
like wait what
you said dude hey
dude that's a trailer shifter eight
minutes eight minutes
six hot minutes um but my question is
like how long have you been playing
guitar because i do see you
fingering around in here yeah
before every word choice hey this is the
we all know the lingo man let's just
tell the truth wednesday tell the truth
wednesday truth wednesday okay well i
started when i was
13. oh you did
that's pretty 13. no i've been playing a
while
do you play well
i'm asking a question he's in a band you
still have no can you play a song right
now yeah easily all right let me see how
you do let me see your fingering he's
also you can also play the drums
uh i really want to play that i want to
look at chin's face to see what he has
to say i think she's played with
[Music]
yeah yeah well we know the song
can you play something we know
that's nice no it's fun
ah
probably not know it but i do chappelle
you can play the guitar
[Music]
go and close
the curtains cause all we need
is say hello light you and me
and a bottle of wine to save the night
brian that's the first time brian's ever
heard that song
you're old huh oh ooh
[Music]
chances
[Music]
he can play you son of a [ __ ] are you
impressed that's pretty cool wait let's
sing james says while you play that i'm
going to bring up the [ __ ] if we can
play them the show yeah you can you're
allowed as long as we don't do it too
long
yeah you guys don't matter you can do it
no you can do it if it's a song i don't
think you can be something okay it's
called uh jane's addiction but the song
is called
says jane says i gotta hear the snap
song
i'm done with sadio chances i thought it
said changed
that's a good song oh great i would love
to see them live they [ __ ] kill uh
dude you can i thought i really thought
you had just started playing guitar
really because you were in here [ __ ]
around i was like i think well because a
lot of times i'm just like learning and
like teaching myself [ __ ] but you don't
know him do you right now you have nice
fingers too i know [ __ ] you i have
and and they're dexterous what's that
you know you can get a lot of
desperation you can rip you can thrash
yeah the kids say
[ __ ] thrash dude all right i was
gonna i wanted
copyright damn come on daddy i know boo
dude uh what's crazy i didn't even
realize until i met my
father
because i didn't know where my musical
background came from my grandpa
he was a guitar player for the church oh
really yeah he would rip wow so that's
how i found that out wow so [ __ ]
everybody that made fun of me when i was
a kid yeah what's up now what's up now
and you just had a you've got a four
grand collection what the [ __ ] up now
[ __ ] you i'm serious dude don't let
brian [ __ ] on it it's really you play
music because you're gonna be you're
gonna be able to do that and do stand-up
forever oh you know i was thinking about
it i was like because you know i do the
band stuff and then [ __ ] the stand up
and i was thinking about i was like man
when i was a kid i i think i've always
just been that way when i was younger i
was skateboarding cheerleading playing
guitar going to punk shows i got i think
it's just always been
it's a good thing but uh in your band
are you playing the instrument you're
you're lead singer so i wrote all the
songs
and then they play them and i sing yeah
yeah that's why my voice is kind of shot
right now okay you guys are practicing
when when's the show march 26th we're at
program skate shop
in uh fullerton
that'd be cool
yeah what's the band called you're gone
where am i at you're in charm oh [ __ ]
that's right why do they call it chicago
i don't know because it's close
i mean 40 minutes outside 40 minutes
yeah that's not close to chicago i'm
staying in lincoln park shout out to the
band hey
yeah i did a show um i did stand up they
they got up and sang
and i had to go do stand up it's the
most nervous i've ever been really yeah
that's the following year why because uh
just before they're rich shows were like
like musical no it was it was for it was
for like the most like richest and
famous people in holly like you know
like
big time people like senators and like i
didn't belong there and they said can
you do stand up no this is i think
there's a fifth one it was like
celebrities yeah i'm a celebrity but it
was at uh well no it was that it was at
the pritzker's house the most the
richest family like like they owned the
area they were in the marriott oh really
and it was at their house which is the
biggest house in southern california and
i get there and i i have the worst car
and i was like what's going on here and
then there was cameras and there were
senators really and so everybody's you
go after lincoln dude i was so nervous i
used to i love lincoln park yeah it was
such a show outside i was like if i'm
going to die here and i i
made it through by the skin of my teeth
dude what's crazy about this i saw that
band live
with chris cornell oh wow they both and
they were great friends they both and
they both and they died the same way
pretty similar right now it was close no
i thought cornell drowned chris no oh
wow wow you don't know i know chris he
doesn't know i was thinking about jeff
buckley jeff buckley oh you think no
that that was years ago yeah i don't
know we're talking yeah
cornell and chesterwood yeah
i want to say
like months apart yeah i was going to
say it was close it was like stupid it
seems like when cornell did he gave them
the kind of the motivation to chest yeah
yeah
it's so puzzling the the problem my
thing with chester had like seven kids
young dude i can't and then cornell has
been tortured kids yeah
is that true yeah tortured cornell's
buried at uh
hollywood forever i went to like the
year
what was that universal song
oh [ __ ] a lot oh black hole son
black
oh
well he did a lot of songs but i mean
that was a rusty cage i mean i mean but
such a shame though man those poor guys
think about the level of despair you
have to have to leave your children yeah
and knowing how much you use your kids
like think about that like you can't
bear it i mean they're set financially
but they're [ __ ] up yeah it's just no
daddy it's the only logical way out of
hell i guess for them yeah that's been
really bad i'm sure noah was off i think
they said he was off his
meds i think he was taking meds or
something it's it's a pretty or changes
meds right and then there was a
conspiracy theory with both of them
right yeah something would like you see
i sam about it yeah i sam about it
yeah i don't really subscribe to it but
goes deep it goes d my buddy uh frank
grillo's uh manager and a great guy who
i knew oh
he's such a good guy
oh yeah he was amazing he was an amazing
guy you knew him yeah i met him through
toby he was a big h2o fan and all this
stuff parkour kid such a good guy
beautiful [ __ ] soul didn't die just
recently yeah he [ __ ] suicide yeah
dude frank was close you know he was
good and and he died yeah but he had
dinner and he was wrestling with this
this depression then he had dinner with
the family and his family's [ __ ]
close his brother is yeah
mm-hmm your own cia big boy yeah great
guy big boy
and and they're all good people man
that's a good family right there and
they're a tight family and chris was a
great [ __ ] guy he he drove he came
all the way out to brea to see me
headline i think he rode out on like a
motorcycle or something i don't know
yeah but anyways but like he came out to
see you yeah he's about to see me
performing he was such a good dude like
a regular dude
he managed uh chadwick
i think i think he used to manage
chadwick uh bozeman uh that's right
that's right oh yeah yeah
right yeah he had big clients he did
very very well i think he had more
margot
robbie you're robin robbie yeah he did
diamond piece he was such a beautiful
song married great wife anyone else want
to go through people commit suicide i
know but it's just it's great
my best friend did when i was okay
all right let's talk about your guitar
collection again
what do you got chen get me out of here
wait hold on wait i'm really i'm really
mad i don't know
i literally okay i accept you you could
have said you you're 100.
you could have said 40 grand i don't
know guitars in any facet i i didn't
know what you could have said four
hundred dollars i just felt like y'all
had this high experience well because
yeah because you were like a lot i know
it is but
but it's not right even for a collector
i'm just saying if you go like this i
mean i i you went i mean i probably own
four thousand dollars worth now if this
was 1965 i'd go holy [ __ ] dude do you
know where i come from i came from
broadway and dobson
i know but four grand
but he was like dude i have like
40 guitars yeah i was like holy [ __ ]
he's like this collection where jeez
400 bucks yeah yeah that's right my
buddy has 35 guitars
another flex from brian i know why
that's like when i bought my porsche my
dad goes my friend has two of them are
you okay come on don't know your friend
i'm one up and tonight yeah you're right
you want to open up it's flex wins some
days i feel like one upping yeah
no no he can do it with weird fingers
ahead
finger away
[Music]
four thousand dollars
it's not a lot
but if you're poor it means the world
that's all i've written so far that's
all i have so that's awesome hey now i'm
just writing it now people now when
people google my network this is gonna
say four thousand thousand dollars
exactly
wait speaking of guitars
where i give you a really beautiful
guitar yeah man have you even touched it
have you ever done it
hold on did you
i bought him a nice a nice guitar give
me that guitar hey we gotta i let
chappelle borrow it
because i don't know okay
more you said it i
you bought him a guitar a nice guitar
it's gathered
in a corner
yeah is it a part of your four thousand
dollar collection or no no no that's not
okay
why did you buy him a guitar he was
super into guitars he remember he wanted
to do guitar he's talking about guitars
to the point yeah yeah the funniest it
was fun it's like me it's like me
wanting a farm you suddenly got into the
guitar with those terrible hands of
yours he was like i want to learn yeah
i had people reach out to me to someone
the guys that like one direction yeah he
wanted a guy in one direction yeah so
much more interesting that would be cool
now i get home i got kids i don't have
time to play the guitar with your broken
fingers no that's my
favorite straight to his house
cause i play it all the time but i and i
want to post me playing it i'm like post
that [ __ ] now truth is out there talking
no my new things was this truth
wednesday truth wednesday no it's subtle
flex wednesday wednesday from seven
wednesdays you told us you went to bora
bora yeah his rich friend has more
guitars than you diving scuba diving
couple other things or
come out here which makes no sense got
rich friends yeah they were in australia
come come back hey once you get out here
okay
yeah i had crazy wine last night how
much was that guitar channel it's in the
thousands yeah your collection just went
up there
oh wait
you bought him a guitar worth thousands
so it's basically not like my guitar but
it's an electric as well let me know let
me get this straight
in there
i don't think so
hey guys
kids you go out playing garbage how much
was the guitar you bought stevie uh a
little over two grand a little over two
grand yeah stevie can play the [ __ ] out
oh yeah he can but
he's like a living room the tom morello
um custom guitar stevie's so talented
he's very talented just plays in his
living room you can play you can do
stand up you can play the guitar do
whatever you want yes no stevie i'd say
stephen and chen are better than me for
sure stevie can really see he plays by
here right he can yeah i play by your
time
mine's like a when i got the guitars
asking stevie said he's like i don't
know man oh yeah steve did i just go i'm
like what yeah it's weird to try to huh
it's here to try to teach someone how to
play because it's like because unless we
all learn like self-taught so we don't
know
you guys aren't gonna be
even crime he was good at until he got
caught i mean you know he's good at
everything everybody get called
stevie's a very smart dude yeah very
smart and a good dude too yeah what do
you got talk to me about kratom dude
dude i thought i'm trying to get you
started on it you're on it every single
day and sometimes i'm on it right now
daddy what's the matter does it give you
energy and make you stay focused freedom
is a super leaf that comes from deep
within the rain forest of south east
asia
farmers have been using kratom all right
for hundreds of years for stamina energy
reduced pain it's all that stuff man
it's my limitless pill alright gain
energy stay focused some people relax
they feel better depending on the strain
all right kratom has been shown to
improve your mood and your brain
superspeciosia is only one ingredient
it's pure kratom leaf
no chemicals known natural ingredients
never do
super specio uses the top 1 of kratom
produced in the world some of the
highest alkaloid levels in the industry
i have alcohol 100 satisfaction
guaranteed or your money back
all right super speed shows is harvested
exclusively from southeast asia and
every harvest is different once the
current supply sells out it can take
months to restock if you have the chance
to save like you do now take advantage
right now you do super speech osha has
given you a massive discount all you
have to do is go to get super leaf dot
com slash fighter use a promo code
fighter get 20 off get super leaf dot
com slash fighter promo code fighter for
20 off get super leaf dot com slash
fighter promo code fighter for 20 20 off
super speed super specio
kratom look you want to learn a language
in your shoot i keep telling you every
week i need to learn spanish you can do
it in your car you can do it 15-minute
lessons really
but dude hold up i need a i need a
learning language how many times i got
to tell you that they'll tell you how
your accent is okay dude is it fun and
is it easy to learn new language why
don't you ask the 10 million
subscriptions they got this is insane
it's fun it's a very easy way to learn
language if you're traveling abroad
connecting a deeper way you want to
impress somebody with your spanish your
friend you want to talk to the bros or
the chicks at the bar exactly forget it
man you're like excuse me
i'm sorry i'm so sorry i'm sorry come on
james bryan i speak french thanks to
babel babel's 15-minute lessons make it
the perfect way to learn a new language
on the go all right it's created by a
hundred language experts
they're teaching methods that have been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian german they got speech
recognition technology okay helps you
improve your pronunciation and your
accent oh my god there's so many ways to
learn with babylon right now you can
purchase a three-month babble
subscription you conditional three
months free that's six months for the
price of three just go to babel.com use
the promo code fighter that's babel.com
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code fighter babble
language for life
total human optimization that's what
it's about that's what on it's about
that's what we're about that's what
we're about we're about focused yeah you
didn't eat a cupcake today and that's
not being optimized i know i regret it
i'm gonna i'm gonna purge when we get
out of here it's okay because get guess
what you can get all your minerals and
all your nutrients you got alpha brain
which is a nootropic you you want good
sleep take your melatonin spread you do
nothing more important than total gut
health yes dude
three sprays you're trying to get a
swollen we got protein powders we got
creatine we got arabic coffee dark roast
we got fat butters elk bars warrior bars
protein bars protein bites mct oil the
bottom line we got it all you can have
you can set up an entire gym for
yourself in your garage oh my god you
never need to leave you didn't even talk
to anybody you really don't because
we got streaming on demand it's home
fitness yeah
there's certifications we have battle
ropes sandbags steel club mesa steel
mazes everything we just told your ass
about audit.com fighter 10 off the
entire dang site oh yeah get you some on
it dot com slash fighter
all right start with this okay so um
recently naomi osaka was playing at the
grand no she was playing at a tennis
tournament when she was doing really
poorly because she was getting heckled
by one guy in the crowd no it says after
a woman
can be heard shouting no naomi you suck
your jackass oh my god yeah so i guess
there were women there were a few
hecklers but there was one that was
being highlighted it was a man who was
constantly kind of heckling her okay the
entire time and she started to break
down she did like worse and worse
progressively as the yeah went on she
struggles with mental health she'll miss
[ __ ] big tournaments and won't oh
really interviews because i wouldn't let
that happen in the tournament they
kicked the [ __ ] guy out or what yeah
well yeah i don't think they kicked him
out she ended up asking for the mic at
the very end if i was sitting next to
that guy i'd be like hey [ __ ] oh yeah
shut the [ __ ] up yeah but there was a
lot of it you know there's also
professional sports you have been a
youth yeah but not attack that's ufc and
that's football this is not in this
tennis tournaments man and a lot of
people including rafael nadal yeah yeah
of all time he actually came out and
said you know what i really feel for her
she's a like young up-and-coming athlete
who has a lot of mental issues and i
feel for her but at the same time you
are a professional athlete and it
unfortunately comes with the territory
i'm with him on this yeah nobody you
paid a ton of money imagine be a
professional yeah imagine
when we get heckled if we [ __ ] start
crying
like yo
eventually i was like look [ __ ] you yeah
i flew all the way out of here i've seen
that this is what i did i've seen it
i saw it i was in that's my show
hopefully tomorrow goes better yeah you
don't do your meet and greets
you don't deserve them angry dude in new
york city
jay take the shirts off the table
you guys aren't getting shirts dave's
just all [ __ ] cool
yeah [ __ ] you guys man you all don't
deserve them you made my brother cry
yeah you made my brother cry no shirts
for you guys you know i've seen it down
have you ever seen that you've seen that
happen oh dude there was like a a
comedian in new york city it you know
like a big boy when you were doing 8 in
the 80s and 90s yeah
it was still acceptable to heckle the
[ __ ] out of somebody sometimes like you
you had a bouncer but
like you just expected people to [ __ ]
with you you know and especially in new
york city and especially drunk irish
guys and especially drunk irish guys
from ireland you know whatever it was
you knew you get a group of dudes and
they were drinking and you knew it was
gonna be a thing now you can either
roast the [ __ ] out of them and make a
part of your show or you can laugh with
them
what you don't want to do is show them
that you're offended
like this one guy i want to say he was a
guy who was always a well-known comic no
but he was a journeyman who who worked
at the comedy club and he was always the
enemy yeah yeah okay okay okay was not
really like their their go-to
for 10 years but probably wasn't
no big show i could i could train for
the nfl never i just don't have the bone
structure sometimes like that and he
goes sir
sir i am working up here
sir i am working up here and you were
uncouth i remember
uncured he said he's not getting good
hey why don't you [ __ ] off that
and hey guys it's amazing your manners
your man
they were like
like that and i had to fight at least
it's funny i know make it funny you know
what he did he was like you know i'm
done i can't do this and he got out and
just got off the stage
now there brian you go out there [ __ ]
he's supposed to you're supposed to be
the emcee damn [ __ ] [ __ ] took his
ball went home dude i [ __ ] went up
there and he said you're a man i love
the guy you were uncool
first thing i said do i go guys
seriously if you're going to be uncouth
i'm going to have to be uncoofed back
i was in i was in
what does she have gin
mike tyson's cannabis oh she's currently
releasing a cbd gummy in the shape of a
bitten ear only in america it's called
mike bites oh that's how things are
gonna crush from mike tyson yep
i thought that was hilarious you could
just see the little bite white fire oh i
just saw it now that's pretty great it's
pretty brilliant they also look
delicious
and it's just a cbd gummy right yeah not
like the mic but these ears actually
taste good
that's funny
actually it might be an edible yeah it's
an edible that was the craziest thing
nuts that was insane not toast yep i
remember being a kid watching it yeah me
too and he was just like i want my
[ __ ] money back
yeah
i remember it very well
i'm just biting the [ __ ] ear
yeah
this is a random one uh apparently there
was a bill that was passed where we no
longer have to do daylight savings i
complain about it all the [ __ ] time
if you have kids dude you know how tough
this is for kids how does it work i
don't understand so we just just
everything
yeah because we're not in the 1920s yeah
i don't know i never understood what
they said
farmers
you know arizona is the only state that
did not yeah it was arizona and hawaii
those were there
anymore so you lose an hour gain and now
we're not going to have that anymore no
no we're just going to stay what we're
wrong
yeah this is the only country that we're
just kidding it's the worst dude for my
son when you sleep well yeah and then
you're they're going to bed super early
waking up crazy early seeing the stats
on that
daylight savings heart attacks go way up
that's not good when you lose a day an
hour of sleep really yes and so not your
kids but yeah and depression and
depression you need sleep
i didn't get much is that why i was sad
yesterday yeah maybe i i couldn't wake
up this morning i had i had to radio for
louisville and i i don't know i was like
i had some
yeah i was like i could sleep so much
longer yeah but also think about it
because i wake up at six five to six is
a world of difference we have six yeah
no matter what every day but five i feel
sick right and you look at the clock it
says six was really five right and
you're in the middle of the day then
when i'm in bed it says nine it's really
eight uh-uh
so quit [ __ ] the clock try having a
baby
that's what he does all day
you sleep in your room yeah
making noise
all right he's a little what times you
get up usually every two hours every two
hours you've got to feed oh is that what
it is yeah yeah every two hours yeah
everyone goes through it
because of the territory yeah
yeah it's fine all righty so this is a
funny video it's just a guy on vacation
who is struggling to put his shorts on i
saw a fickey and i thought you'd
probably use thick with three or two c's
two c's didn't you trade mark three they
may not want to do it but bar still
could have used it and i would not
complain sure i love bar stool
oh my god he has
that one
that's a muffin top
[ __ ] fat your whole life come on man
it's a [ __ ] button he's like i've
been fat your whole life
gotta have that second plate every
[ __ ] time huh
[ __ ] fat
when i get some bigger pants
he was so upset
wow i just don't know when those pants
would have fit they look too small for
his frame
yeah they feel like yeah yeah they look
super small for us right now i always
had cousins who were the same way they
never wanted to up their pant size when
they grew they always wanted to say like
oh i'm a size 25 but then they look like
they're like spilling over the jeans you
know i was like that the long for the
longest time with shoes what i'd be like
you just squeeze your feet into it yeah
but like i'm 11. and then i'm like what
the [ __ ] am i doing dude i just recently
started getting 14.
you got you yeah 14. your arch you're
you lose your arch so your foot gets
bigger as you get older
14s now 70 or 14. these are these are i
got these are 14s i'm all 14s now mm-hmm
and then some 14s are great and some are
swimming in them but but it's a [ __ ] to
get 14s huh that's what was already a
[ __ ] to get 13.
13 is hard to get them 14.
makes sense yeah because it's not too
many 14s out there yeah
anything you want to flex on
uh i have a 10 i have a 10 and a half
and now i'm wearing i'm wearing an 11
right now with these in those big flags
because my feet need to pay for those
dudes i'm not trying to make jokes dude
these are cool sneakers
it didn't get hard to paint though i'm
answering story the guy who starred
those now he's crushing it who why
what's the story on clouds yeah i don't
know anything about it
you should look into it why
they started now it's blown up it's like
a swiss engineer i forget yeah
i mean they're very [ __ ] i have to be
honest they can shoot for transgenders i
mean
they're very comfortable
i own three pairs yeah not of these but
different ones
they're a little bit tricky but they're
nice why are they tricky i mean the way
they look you either love them or you
hate him
it's just like a basic but this is like
a basic yeah yeah i'm just a cute kid
with it there is some business talk
going on what else you got to do all
right
got my dungarees kevin holland ufc
fighter yeah
him and his buddy i just want to be this
guy
this is badass him and his buddy took
down a guy that was a shooting in a
restaurant in a raw sushi restaurant
mainstream media doesn't realize that
kevin holland's complete badass and they
go a guy who has some training in mma
took him out like
training how about you [ __ ] get your
facts straight and say ufc world-class
fighter takes out guy yeah
and this is the second time he's done
something like uh to help prevent or you
know help people he's having trouble the
first time was when there was someone
that got carjacked and he went after the
guy as well and the second time he's
done something like this him and his
buddy his buddy also helped out a lot
too but apparently kevin got him they
both got the guy's gun he was an active
shooter in a sushi he was shooting up in
the in the air there yeah why were you
shooting the air he seems like he's like
out a
homeless kind of crazy person see what
happens here does kevin talk about it or
no yeah
then we heard a big
loud bang i thought it was champagne
bottle popping you know because people
behind us inside they're having a
birthday party
and uh
i go to look around and see people
running like they had like uh
they look like death on their face you
know just super worried
and so you know i'm like all right well
we know what this is so get a little low
you know
uh check the corner i see the gun the
guys grab the guy but the gun's facing
right towards where we are so i'm like
i'm gonna make a move this way you know
what i mean get around this so i don't
have to worry about it so i go around
the other side i come up behind the guy
grab a chair i was going to smack him
with a chair but when you get to the
side you can't really see who the
shooter is whether it's the
guy on top of the guy on bottom exactly
i was facing one way and then we heard a
big loud bang i thought it was champagne
bottle popping you know
todd was mainly holding the guy's hand
trying to stop squeezing the trigger so
then you know we apply the gun out of
that guy's hand
i go ahead i pull him into my uh into my
lap put the hooks in
with a rear neck and choke
my uh baby uncle's sitting there he's
looking at me you know he's her being
with the dreads hanging out the back you
know i mean skinny hurt that's what i
call him right there at that moment and
he's like uh he's not asleep he's not
asleep all right he's asleep so as soon
as you sleep you know i let go the choke
slid out on top got full mount stretched
the arms out so he couldn't reach for
anything we grabbed his backpack
threw his backpack off to the side made
sure the gun was out of play pretty good
he couldn't reach for anything killed
his head so he couldn't bite me
and you know a few minutes later i mean
i never saw the police pull up that fast
so good job used gpd
they're pretty quick
you know handcuffed the guy and you know
the rap you know
everybody was blind badass
attempt to do like a mass shooting yes
badass dude yep love kevin holland
amazing
oh that's the old story oh when the uh
the carjacker yep
he's like batman
yeah yeah he just keeps what's he doing
there is he got his arm
wrapped around is he from houston
i think he moved down there is he
originally from i'm not sure
he's just holding that guy oh okay he's
got him like oh from your neighborhood
chasing bag he's choking him with his
horn yeah
cop's like we'll take it from here
yeah that's
he's a badass that's the guy oh you
could tell he's not all there man just
by his face
damn he got choked out he pumped a boat
bruising on the neck good he definitely
got jumping he didn't know shout out to
kevin holland man right yeah he's
straight you can see he's crazy
um let's go to another quick mma one
because we talked about this on last
episode how jake paul challenged dana
white yeah so this is dana white's
response to him and it's not the best
response he was on logan paul's show
that's another crazy thing he was on
yeah
he shouldn't even be fighting conor
mcgregor these guys the pauls which is
weird because there's these guys depauls
even though
he's in front of logan paul these guys
the pauls are [ __ ] huge logan's huge
his brother jake is huge what's your
brother six foot one 210 pounds conor
mcgregor 145 155 pounds there's weight
classes for a reason do you think jake
could make 170 white ass logan paul and
logan says i don't think so yeah exactly
and it's a stretch for conor fight at
170. fought nate diaz at 170. this isn't
[ __ ]
that isn't his [ __ ] weight that's not
even close
he hasn't been 145 forever though
he's bigger
yeah he looks way bigger right now and
then uh dana white is betting i agree
dana white is begging for a ds counter
fight for the third time jake paul
talking jake paul's saying this he goes
they have fought at 100 170 pounds in
both their fights i will fight coming at
175 pounds no problem stop making
excuses [ __ ]
how big is uh have you met jake how big
is he's big big
cotter's thick right now too though
yeah connor's not small man yeah
a lot shorter than uh jake though or i
think jake's like six right yeah
babysitting your money's out yeah
oh yeah
six one six one
guy's so great he's only 25 i didn't
realize that
191
when he fought woodley's 181
190 yeah he's big man yeah 175's he's
definitely bigger but i mean you know
the it's in the octagon so
yeah yeah i think it's such an
intriguing fight
at 175.
[ __ ] at 175 i think connor would give
him a real you should oh yeah he should
yeah it'd be great if they did it yeah
dan was like he's like danny goes i
never say no anymore because i might say
it's impossible but you see i've learned
not to say anything's impossible yeah
i could see it happen
they're gonna do it anyway might as well
do in the ufc yeah for sure
huge payday um so these two youtubers
the couple
they are seeing honey yeah they try to
stay they try to youtube a video of them
like sneaking into a
target staying there all night and then
leaving so they got arrested and by the
way they didn't even stay there all
night they left at like 3 a.m and they
came back eight in the morning pretend
like they were there all day to film
again okay right
okay so think about doing oh that's them
they're facing up to seven years in
prison now for that she's pretty
sure she looks like she's been crying
so they broke into target and just right
or they broke in hours and then once
they they're like hit in the rack
remember that movie career opportunities
long time
deserve jail time oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because they the uh thing about the
resources that they've used on the
taxpayers money yeah and him making a
fake narrative it's the same thing as
like these girls like accusing chris
brown of rape and then you see what
happened with that no girl cues in my
rape
when he was releasing an album he goes
i'm telling you guys you're gonna learn
like every time i'm coming out with
something you guys try to push this
[ __ ] on me the media jumps all over
it so he releases a voice memo and text
of her being like that dick was so good
i can't wait to [ __ ] you again he's like
this is the girl her attorney was like
i'm out like i didn't know this existed
yeah it's a long
it's a long back so he goes uh this is
december 31st 2020.
she goes oh [ __ ] okay i'll get one i
definitely didn't bust inside you just
was hella faded so i wanted to be sure
kissy face
she put okay babe that's fine i want to
[ __ ] you tonight at midnight where are
you at she keeps texting where are you
at bay
then after she press charges
hey it's blank this my new number here's
new number that's fast yeah since in l.a
now gotta get it right
what an [ __ ] and then
yep where are you at home i live in
hollywood word let's link later today
okay bet your place for mine mine should
go in jail for this oh okay bet you got
e i i didn't get to take it last time we
met nah there was my homies i don't
begin it unless my homies got it
okay we can be chill tonight i'll try to
find some where you when she hits him up
what are you doing crying emoji what's
up i had some [ __ ] to handle yesterday
where are you at right now why what's up
i want to come over i'm bored make some
time for me tonight and then he
obviously ignores her yeah so i fell
asleep no
i'm not in my period uh i have a
question do you just be wanting to [ __ ]
me or can we hang out like some chill
[ __ ] during the day i know you'd be busy
it's cool if you just want to [ __ ] i
just want to know my role
he doesn't respond she goes okay never
mind sends a picture
where are you at bay you up i'm coming
home with you tonight we we at the same
party lol where are you at months later
i'm sorry i'm high as [ __ ] i just wanted
to come over no reply from christopher
and by the way so she filed that stuff
on january so this is already past
february march now what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm sorry i'm high as [ __ ] one come over
where y'at can i come over happy
birthday babe where's your skate party
tonight will everybody to see you again
sexy pic
now what happened missing you you were
honestly the best i've had i just wanted
again why are you playing with me leaves
a voice note
yeah clearly love the wee wee goddamn
missing you you're honestly the best
[ __ ] i've ever had won again why you
playing with me again you knew full well
i wasn't pressing you about no blank you
told me to stay and i'm gonna try and
play me that's crazy i didn't deserve
that but you definitely got it
um and then if you want to hear the
voice message it's up to you no it's
okay i've heard enough the bottom line
is what happens so you're trying to
destroy someone's life and you're
[ __ ] oh he's coming after her he
should come out you should but the
prosecutor she should serve
you're trying
you're trying to murder somebody just so
you know when you when you accuse
somebody or something they didn't do
like rape you're trying to murder them
but they're don't make it anything there
needs to be repercussions of course
there has to be because there should be
he's releasing
but most people don't have that
especially if it's 20 years old 25 years
old you don't have anything like that
all you can do is go what the [ __ ] are
you talking about yeah okay mm-hmm and
and that
what happens we should pay a price yeah
yeah nothing happens yeah i think he
said he's going after him he should go
after he should make an example should
be an automatic rule
you're literally a murderer you're
[ __ ] a murderer you're trying to ruin
his career yeah and obviously because
rihanna's stuff is like it's so easy for
me to be like look at him back again
so the media makes so much money on that
clickbait yeah and chris brown's like
dude i've worked on myself i'm not into
this [ __ ] man i don't [ __ ] like that
anymore this isn't what i do yeah i'm
just going after him that girl should do
i think two years minimum i agree yeah
you gotta you gotta make it this guy
paul butler who's a msnbc columnist was
talking about how jessie smellette
shouldn't
do be due time and it was elite white
the elite white establishment that one
is that what is that what do you blame
them and it's like dude is that what he
really [ __ ] wanted a lot of black and
white people everybody nobody
everybody's like this guy's a huge
narcissistic [ __ ]
it's not a race thing if a white guy did
that
he should hate him yeah more it doesn't
matter
it's so easy it's overrated oh butlers
jesse smart such a piece his point was
that he shouldn't do time i'm surprised
you watched that no it's an article it's
it's in my feed it's not it was a bit
it's actually news fox news picked it up
and they were like you know
look at this that's insane that that's
their logic it's so silly it just
doesn't do anybody any good why don't
you defend him yeah um the last one is
just dl hugley responded to kanye so i
guess i'm not sure where he said this
but someone asked him about the whole
kanye stuff how he's doing all those
texts and everything with to kim
kardashian and the kids whatever he said
it's bullying it's harassment yeah so
this is what uh deal hughley says
uh
dale said i think that i've watched too
many times when things like that happen
a woman or somebody's not believed and
then things escalate he's stalking her
you can think it's cute if it was my
daughter i do something about it i don't
think it's funny i think that you can
you can't write a beats so good that you
get to do these things and society
laughs it off because say well she's
shown she's showing her ass all the time
and he's this and that difference
between him and a restraining order is
about 20 hits and a couple hundred
million dollars yeah
and then
right here um uh hugely respond to uh
kanye's ain't no way in hell i'd ever be
scared of a dude who wears i know what
you did last summer boot
i said that no no
comics
he also expressed kindness just too bad
kanye's just too bad acting like a nut
won't stop pete uh from busting one hmm
ain't it aware that cunning spoiler has
all these goons who will kill for him
but no one not one of them will ever get
his prescriptions filled here's a
thought
while you're on your way to kill me in
calabasas i deny oc deal huge around
calabasas by the way uh how about
somebody drop by cbs and pick up his
xanax damn so kanye said something uh he
goes i can't afford to hurt you
um oh no sorry that was
kanye's is something nice i want to hurt
you
he's like a woke plant he's like if this
is the best you got woke left like dale
hughley
schultz he made a
great point on uh
flagrant two he was like it's all this
is a little too convenient because the
kardashians are dropping their hulu
reality series and all this is coming
out now like all this drama yeah like it
keeps them in the news and then they're
they're off to hulu he's like i don't
know man
and then also i didn't know this pete
davison
knew he was gonna post those texts sent
to a buddy to post for him because he
doesn't have social media his friend
texts
it's all little it's too convenient also
don't make this public dude but he's
making it possible yeah it's weird and
you know and you knew you were going to
post it i got super skeptical yeah me
too it all just seems a little too weird
what uh
there was some other [ __ ] that he was
doing he just keeps making everything
public including his correspondences
with uh it's not good kim it's not good
no
but i'm all checked out on this
[ __ ] it's just hard for me to just like
i'm like how does this really affect i
like that piece to defend himself now
and like firing back at it yeah i think
that's good well yeah if it's if he's if
it's real i don't know it's a little bit
dangerous
all of it's weird oh that's [ __ ]
weird all that's [ __ ] weird it's like
oh yeah it's all the time oh just move
on everybody yeah
i'm going i'm gonna go home to my four
thousand dollar guitar collection
you guys i know it's five thousand now
dude five thousand dollars
we added money too yeah we had a money
we made five you made a grand for this
podcast so
thank you jen
yep that's it all right kids uh this
saturday we have cal badass fight
campaign for the ufc london 1 p.m on
think boy only chris deleo dye myself
that is 1pm
saturday day on the thick boy youtube
channel uh
los angeles california hollywood improv
may 23rd will be the seventh job and
friends that's 8 p.m the seventh one
this could be our seventh sold-out show
oh [ __ ] i know dude we've been doing the
goddamn thing uh but that's this coming
wednesday once you're only 8 p.m
shopping friends with some bangers on
there and then also next week thursday
friday saturday chicago schomburg improv
march 24-26 and then phoenix just went
on sale april 14th through the 16th the
new thick boy gear this uh st patrick's
day green hoodie and the shirt i wore
during the deadlifts just what is going
on sale that is tomorrow morning and
also the thick mudder shirts for the
april 9th thick mudder at 10 30 a.m sign
up at toughmutter.com it's a 10 30 a.m
thick mudder there's a 5k and 15k used
promo code thickboy for 10 off
and that's it kids
boom see you this weekend
in louisville kentucky kids
uh tomorrow
friday saturday and in miami florida
miami improv march 25-27 i got tampa
florida i'm back in florida april 15 16.
i'm back in florida again april 21 23 at
the masonic theater port charlotte
florida then i go to wiseguys in las
vegas april 28 to 30. shooting my
special
uh may 19th oh [ __ ] in the brea improv
yeah confirm we're good yes
awesome embracing firm yeah it's
exciting tell them
april 8th and april 9th i'll be in salt
lake city at wise guys comedy club then
may 6th and 7th new comedy club in san
diego called my drop comedy club
um
it do you i think it used to be the old
[ __ ] gosh i can't remember and then
i'm doing a one night or may 12th in my
hometown uh at stand-up live in phoenix
nice boom
that's it love you guys